[музика]
рем більше не тисни 100 c
особливі вайс вигляд
[музика]
цим пасту по woven перед вариться
назвав і що і руїну плошки вікторію
розтушовано в самому центрі риму уступу
вована прикидається на граматиці
tonight для вас плиту інших то магніт для
наркоторговців місць його влада не має шамани
робити то мужик чи ви вирішили взяти
ініціативу в свої руки відразу сич
перебуваєте
разом вам у магазині морозова дніпро та
круза місця
джурдже талери чоловіка побачивши його в такому
втомимося в дістати зайнятий банер і наш
вечір побоюватися ідея пилова в тому що
завгодно ти місця в їхні жителі то бізнес
ініціативи та smooth цієї владу дієти
трапилися брут і наркотики і нехай і не
проблема району на клуб лущі вікторію
проте сідайте кілометрі злетіти
наука latter ім ситуація штайгер ш ц
територія мафії ставок і на її волосся та
боротьбу 1 разом вежі
тут за снував і центр для дітей та молоді
і видного на роботу бібліотекою як була
закрита вже багата уроки
боже і години проводять і розум віссю джуму
ключ до перемоги поверни мазь на миску
вікторіо активісти архітектурка умовити
по передній план у нової та площі
трубу досягти завдань і можна його
caviar не в центрі
чому ніби каталізатором змін у тему
їх про що ще влада розбила США
наша мета до місця пункту ми кожному я до
комору буде тьмяно його то наші жити від
бюрократії та низьких цін та ліцензій та
ми перед форму тепло щука чудово місяців
виступайте манула го року я краще
джордану з друзям і вид крим тут caviar
new
winscp одягаєте що скоро районів холу
стану безпечним щось комфортним для
видвидовача